this is the speaks gazelle the smallest  of the gazelle species sadly it is also  one of the most endangered they max out  at around two feet and forty pounds  their biggest feature is their nose  which can puff up to the size of a  tennis ball when excited native to the  Horn of Africa they live in semi desert  grasslands and feed on grass herbs  shrubs and other plants in the 80s they  were one of the most abundant gazelle  species in parts of Ethiopia and Somalia  but today the eath European population  is close to extinction  while numbers in Somalia have greatly  decreased a combination of hunting  droughts and over grazing has decimated  the population this is the speakes  gazelle